- [Voiceover] We have many
videos on Khan Academy
on things like evolution
and natural selection.
We think we have a fairly
solid understanding
of how life can evolve
to give us the variety,
the diversity, and the complexity
that we've seen around us,
but it still leaves unanswered
a very fundamental question.
And this might be the
biggest question known to us,
and that is the origins of life.
How did life first
emerge, at least on Earth,
and that even starts to
lead to other questions
about is there life outside of this planet
and what could it be like?
And so let's start with
what we actually know
and I'm gonna start with a timeline.
So let's go one billion years ago,
let's go two billion years ago,
three billion years ago,
four billion years ago.
So this is now.
And once again, we're talking
about a billion years ago.
You'll sometimes see the abbreviation BYA,
billion years ago, which
is an unfathomable amount
of time going into the past.
But we know that Earth along with the rest
of the solar system was formed
around 4.6,
4.6 billion
years ago,
so that's when Earth was formed.
And right at 4.6 or
even, you wait a casual
100 million years after
that 4.5 billion years ago,
we believe that Earth wasn't very suitable
for even very simple life to form,
and that's because the solar
system was a crazy place.
You had collisions of all scales
happening all of the time.
The moon itself was
formed from the collision
of two planet-sized objects,
one we call it the proto-Earth
and another planet-sized
object and they collided
and then they started to spin around
and one part became the moon.
It was tidally linked with the Earth.
But you can imagine,
that's not an environment
where it would be easy for life to form.
And even once the moon was formed,
you had a heavy bombardment of things
in the solar system, the solar
system was a messy place.
It took a long time for the stability
that we now observe out there.
And so that continued, we believe,
until about 3.9 billion years ago,
which is the earliest
that we currently think
that Earth might have
been suitable for life.
Before that, there might have been pockets
where the bombardment
stops and maybe some type
of primitive life might have formed,
but then they would have gone away
with the heavy bombardment.
But who knows?
Maybe they could have
survived that somehow.
But that's the current mainstream belief.
The other thing we know is
that we see fossil evidence
for life 3.5 billions years ago.
And these are stromatolites.
This is fossil evidence, microorganisms,
they formed these structures
that actually continue
to be formed today,
these types of structures
continue to be formed today.
And although it might not
feel like microorganisms
are complex life, when you
think about what has to happen
within a microorganism, they're
actually incredibly complex,
and especially if you compare them
to very simple, non-living organisms.
So our current belief is someplace
in this region life must
have arisen on Earth.
But that still doesn't,
even if we were able
to answer that question, oh,
it was exactly 3.7 billion
years ago was the first
time that some RNA decided,
or not decided, ended up getting
in the right confirmation
so it could replicate itself in some way,
even if we know that date,
it still leaves unanswered
maybe the more interesting
question, which is the how.
The how is really, at least
to me, more important,
more interesting than the when.
And to the how question, there's
a couple of layers on it.
The first is, let's just
start with the most simple
molecules that we would
have expected to find
on early Earth.
Here are some examples
of it right over here.
This is H2O, or more
commonly-known as water.
Right over here is CO2, more
commonly-known as carbon.
That's a little hard to see,
let me do it with a lighter color.
So we have
carbon dioxide right over here.
Here we have molecular
nitrogen, you have some ammonia,
you have some phosphate, and
many other of the elements
that we see on Earth today,
they might have been available
in that early Earth, but
how do they form at least,
even the next step up, which
is the slightly more complex,
or actually a good bit more
complex organic molecules.
And when people talk about
organic molecules they might
be talking about things like this.
These are amino acids.
These are the building blocks
of proteins, amino acids.
You see over here nucleotides.
These are the building blocks
of RNA, DNA, other things.
And so the first question is,
and these aren't the only
simple organic molecules.
You could think about sugars
and all sorts of other things.
But the question is, is it realistic?
Do we at least understand how we can go
from these very simple molecules up here
to these more complex, often
called organic, molecules?
And the simple answer is we
now have a lot of evidence
that this is doable,
that you can go from these
things to these things,
abiotically, without the presence of life.
You'll hear that word abiotic a lot.
Think about it, antibiotic,
you're killing life,
you're killing bacteria.
Abiotic, that is without life.
And the points of
evidence that we now have
are we believe and we've seen evidence
that there's amino acids and
organic molecules related
to them on comets,
meteorites, on other planets,
that they formed spontaneously in space,
once again, without the
presence of life there.
We've even been able to form amino acids
and other molecules like this
from these more simple
elements in the laboratory.
The most famous experiment there
is the Miller and Urey Experiment.
This was in the 1950's,
where they were able to show
with some energy, they provided a spark.
You could imagine that in the early Earth
it could have been from lighting.
And they tried to set up a mix
of gases that they believed
was similar to the atmospheric
mix in the early Earth
which didn't have much oxygen
in the atmosphere then.
We needed life to
actually start to produce
some of that oxygen.
And even though today we think
that they probably didn't
have the mix of gases right,
they did do something significant.
They were able to show
that with that mix of gases
at least they thought
were in that atmosphere,
and some energy being
added to that system,
that they were able to form some
of these organic molecules.
So we should feel pretty good
that at least this first step is doable.
Now the next question is
these organic molecules
by themselves, that's not life.
In fact, these aren't even
the most complex molecules
that are, we believe, essential for life.
Proteins are where things start
to get really interesting,
and a protein,
a protein,
or proteins are one of the places,
a protein might have
thousands of amino acids,
thousands
of amino acids.
Things like DNA and RNA,
also we believe essential
for life, or at least life as we know it,
could be made up of tens
of millions of nucleotides
for one DNA molecule.
So for example, this is just a small part
of a DNA molecule, but
you can already see much,
much more complex than
what we see over here.
And there, too, we have
evidence that you can go
from the amino acids to the proteins,
or you can go from the
nucleotides to the DNA
without the presence of life,
that these things can happen spontaneously
if you have the right context,
the right energy available,
some people believe,
or it's been observed,
that if you have the right surfaces
that these molecules can be
organized in the right way
to form these more complex things.
Now, I know what you're thinking.
Alright, proteins are really cool,
DNA, RNA is really cool, but
then how does that become life?
At what point would we start going,
"That was a proto-life form?"
And this is where we
really get into the area
of the unknown because we don't know.
And there's a couple of
hypotheses out there.
One of them is called
the RNA World Hypothesis.
I'll write that down.
RNA
World
Hypothesis.
And this is the idea
that the first proto-life
was self-replicating RNA molecules.
And the reason why people tend to focus in
on RNA a little bit more than DNA is
that even in cells today,
RNA doesn't just store information,
it can actually play a role as a catalyst.
And when you think about things like tRNA
and you think about ribosomal RNA.
And so maybe some of that
first proto-life was RNA,
information that replicated itself
and catalyzed the replication of itself.
Maybe it somehow got organized
into membrane-bound structures
so it could separate
so you had environments
that were separated
from the outside world.
But the simple answer is we don't know.
Another mainstream hypothesis
is the Metabolism First Hypothesis.
Metabolism
Metabolism First.
And this is the idea that
a lot of basic pathways
that you might study
in a biochemistry book,
that these were first
just happening, well,
all of this could have been happening
in this primordial soup where you had
these organic molecules
in the right conditions,
maybe around heat vents and whatever else,
but the Metabolism First is
that some of these mechanisms
that we now study in biochemistry,
these might have happened
outside of a cell
or outside of life and they
just kept creating more
and more complexity, but
at some point these things
started happening in self-organizing,
membrane-bound structures.
Maybe there's some kind
of combination of the two.
The simple answer is we just don't know,
but there's some fascinating clues.
Even if we observe current biology,
and even in fact if we
see the commonalities
of things that happen,
central dogma of biology,
if we see how proteins,
which structures are common
to all life as we know
it, it might give us clues
or hints at what some of
that very earliest life
or proto-life was actually like.